the ATF had this operation where they
were looking at straw purchasers or
Firearms basically people buying up a
specific type of firearms that were on
the shopping list that the cartels
wanted to buy
including uh you know 50 cows FN five
seven pistols which are small pistols
with a high velocity round that will go
through a bulletproof vest
um
AR-15s of all kinds that could quickly
be modified into full auto down in
Mexico
with a with a drilling a few holes and
making a few things to them
so these people were buying all these
the ATF was watching them and allowing
them to walk those Firearms into Mexico
under the guise of trying to track them
somehow
which doesn't make a lot of sense for
most people to kind of look at that
operation the only people who found the
only reason people found out about it
was because of the murder of a few
federal agents of the U.S federal agents
that were killed with those guns one of
my friends was shot with one of those
pistols outside of his house and they
shot him and they shot her his wife both
of them were killed daughter was in the
back seat lost the part of her arm
when that happened the guns were unique
they were like oh we didn't never let
the Mata police yes is what they call
them they're the cop killers
I haven't seen those before
so they were unique and interesting and
later on in life I was watching CNN and
seeing the hearings going on I was like
oh that's where they came from
uh
two federal agents changed a lot it was
politicized there was a whole scandal up
here but in Mexico how many people died
with those Firearms you know being let
down being let go down there and also
what type of sentiment you think the
local populace has of the United States
after all those guns were basically
handed over to some of these groups
if gun trafficking is another GI part of
the equation part of the problem down
there as far as uh as far as the amount
of Munitions uh weapons and
now we were also getting uh tradecraft
material from conflict zones outside of
Mexico so
weaponized drones the first time we saw
uh some of those weaponized drones was
uh in Syria
and like like a few weeks later you know
grenades were being dropped on the roofs
of some public officials uh Bill cartels
are using drones that's been going on
for a while there's a place in Michoacan
and has some pretty interesting videos
and the the interesting part of it is
because the federal police down there
are actually working hand in hand with a
United cartels Group which is basically
the local cartels to try and fight off
the new generation cartel moving into
Michoacan so even the federal forces are
fighting with the cartels to try and
keep this larger cartel out and there's
videos of these uh civilian drones
basically dropping explosives uh they
found some explosive testing ranges out
there that are basically replicating
stuff that you would see the IRA use
during the con during the troubles out
there from homemade mortars
um you know IEDs have been used in
Mexico that not that much but they're
they're making like a presence again you
know we don't have a lot of ordinance
around like Iraq but we do have a big
mining industry down there so mining
mining explosives of all kinds are
pretty easy to get
so you start seeing that and also I mean
there's some exotic Weaponry coming in
from the south now and from the ocean
now that some of it is probably a U.S
military equipment sold to various South
American governments that are now
not as stable as they were and they're
kind of making their way into black
market so a lot of those uh 50 cal and
vehicle mounted technical type machine
guns and some of the RPGs and
uh man pads or remote control guided
missiles that you that have been found
in cartel hands are probably come making
their way up from down south to get
these like multi-million dollar systems
like the highmar system in the in the
Ukraine you get like super sophisticated
advanced technology or we're not so like
this is like military grade I'm not sure
what the applications would be exactly
in Mexico some of them some are
sophisticated stuff I see in our man
pads which is basically remote guided
missiles I've seen some of those found
out what is the application exactly
a display of power there are no-fly
zones over parts of Mexico
for this reason the new generation
cartel took down a helicopter
there's been incidents of military
helicopters falling from the sky and it
it they said that it was mechanical
issues
but again I'm not I'm not gonna do
conspiracy theories out there but
there's there's a lot of videos on Tick
Tock of uh Cena Laura cartel forces at
parties you know carrying around uh
rocket launchers on their backs and you
know and so so there's an increased
probability of mechanical failures over
those areas when you're flying a
helicopter yeah there's no fly zones
over certain parts of Mexico okay and uh
um another thing you're seeing now is
night vision uh night vision equipment
uh that is clearly military grade from
the US that was probably abandoned in
some War Field out there so maybe
Afghanistan or somewhere like that and
it's uh it's being found in safe houses
and in the hands of cartel forces you
want to talk about a scary opponent
somebody wearing night vision
with a suppressed firearm those types of
capabilities are now out there
also there's this tendency to think and
every now and then you'll see these
cartel videos with these guys carrying
around these 50 cows and they show up
they stand there like yeah you know the
boasting about the rifles and everybody
laughed at them because
the 50 cal or anything like that without
an optic on it you know is like you're
gonna shoot you're praying shoot
basically see if you can hit anything
with it uh but now there's a a few of my
sources I've seen you know sophisticated
uh laser-guided uh rangefinders and and
sighting systems on some of these that
are being found out there how much
damage can 50 cal what's the application
they started getting them specifically
with the proliferation of armored
vehicles in Mexico Mexico has a giant
industry and armored vehicles as far as
so there's a race in terms of uh
armoring like protecting especially high
value targets and then weapons they can
deal with those armored protected high
value targets there was a an attempted
assassination of a state prosecutor
somewhere in I think central Mexico I
forget exactly where but she was uh
riding around up armored uh Jeep
uh Cherokee I think it was and their
main means of of uh Firepower was 50
cows and that car was left in pieces he
survived in it so I think the armored
vehicle company that sold her that
vehicle has it in the display room
uh then before my time probably two
three years before I was actually active
they tried to kill the head of public
Security in in the state of Baja and
with him it was a grenade launcher 40
millimeter grenade launcher it uh it
skipped off the the armored vehicle and
landed in the the car behind it made the
back explode uh one of the guys that I
used to work with was actually in that
car he's arrived it
um but you started to see oh they're you
know using our vehicles now let's get 50
caliber now to try and defeat that armor
uh
so that yeah there's there's always this
uh
this race of Technology basically down
there armored vehicles
you know how to take on an armored
vehicle well there's a few ways 50 Cals
you know if you can mount them in a
right way and shoot at a car like that
or a bunch of kids with balloons and uh
acrylic paint
on the front windshield and blind the
vehicle so it doesn't so they can't
drive it anymore there's another way a
tow line across a road painted like the
painted painted black so you can't see
it
and cut the thing in half again I'm not
saying any secrets these are things that
people have seen out there uh
the shoot at the radiator you know uh
some of these radiators are not uh even
the more sophisticated uh Vehicles out
there don't have a sufficient uh
armoring around the radiator or the
battery housing on some of these
vehicles
there was a case of a guy I think a
nickname was El pelalakas or something
like that I haven't seen Aloha Curry
level cartel guy he had a normal vehicle
he was you know riding around and he got
ambushed he shot at his car he was like
ah I have armor you can't shoot me and
somebody went up to his car and just put
the barrel right in the locking
mechanism
and that kind of you know so
it's an interesting place as far as
people uh getting certain types of guns
armor is prolific down there I mean
everybody down there look at all carton
levels you see them wearing plate armor
so that's an issue it's not like you can
shoot somebody Square in the chest and
go down are they afraid to kill
Americans
so I know I was traveling in Ukraine on
the front
so like a lot of the journalists were
traveling like armored vehicles
and at first I was like it seems like
this would attract attention yeah like
it seems like they would want to hit
those targets but then then I realized
over time as I learned
there's a there's a fear of killing
Americans there could be a drastic
escalation of yeah it's not worth it
conflict it's taking a beehive yeah
it's yeah there's there's there is a
tendency to shy away or stay away from
that you know I mean these they don't
want the Heat or the attention outside
of that everyone's game everyone's game
but also there's been many cases of
Americans being killed down there I mean
we saw the Mormon Massacre uh that
happened down there and all of them were
American Mexican they had both
nationalities and blonde kids you know
white being a massacred in the middle of
a desert uh and the car is uh basically
Catching Fire this happened and you know
America Americans uh sent the FBI down
there to kind of review some of what
happened down there
and uh I think that was when Trump
started uh talking about kind of
Reviving this whole notion of cartels
being labeled as a terrorist
organization probably more for of a
political
pressure point he was using to try and
get Mexico to reinforce its Southern
border which
it hasn't but there's escalation you
know oh this this already happened and
nothing happened so we can probably get
away with it you know and again there's
a newer generation moving forward now of
people coming into power more brutal
more technically Savvy well they have
the experience of their parents and the
people behind them and what they've done
and one gotten away with and now yeah
more Savvy about information Warfare
their main recruiting tool is tick tock
to go to Tech talk and you'll see a
bunch of these kids at a narco party
dancing around and some of these are
videos like cartel members filming other
cartel members in cartel control
territory and that's a window into that
life for
who's on Tech talk now kids
and the enticing aspect of that is the
money
the fun
the High Roller life and the possibility
of making it to a level you know yeah a
Fame of uh respect
power
money here in the US somebody might you
know I want a mansion you know like that
that's their mindset I want to live you
know like that rapper
down there I mean if you can buy a house
for your mom you know or pay off some
debts that you might have or a car
that's enough to kill for
so you also one of the many things you
did is uh you did security try to
protect in this in this war try to
protect people high value people yeah
how do you do you and others how is it
possible to protect a high value Target
like a celebrity or an important
politician in the situation so I was I
was tasked to protect the governor of
Baja and his family I was basically
replacing a whole contingency of people
that were already there that turned out
to be corrupted that wasn't my field I
was operational I was working with other
people doing the counter narcotic stuff
and uh the director of the institution
that I was in basically called me and
said hey uh
you're going to go and replace this of
these people and like what happened to
them well
so you were known as a person that could
be kind of trusted I was tasked for that
so I I think they considered that and uh
and I I specifically worked for uh a
governor named uh Jose
uh who was probably one of the best
Governors we have had in the state and
people want to see if I'm trustworthy or
not they can ask him directly and I I
still speak to some members of his
family and we're still you know friends
in that way it's protecting people like
technically a difficult problem to solve
for my experience in that time and in
place he was basically spearheading you
know counter the drug war in Baja when
he was in power so he had threats from
all over not only him but his family
first thing I realized working that job
in Mexico is that uh we had
we had people coming in to do
specialized training of that regard
Israelis you know teaching us how they
would do things in Israel that didn't
make a lot of sense for us in Mexico you
know we had people that had some Secret
Service experience kind of show us how
showing us how they would do like
celebrity the bodyguarding or
bodyguarding somebody maybe in
California of that nature
didn't make sense for us then we got to
experience some cross training with some
uh nsw Naval Naval special Warfare
people who were coming off uh protection
details in Afghanistan and Iraq is there
some useful cross over there we were
struggling with the acceptance that we
were basically doing protection details
in a war zone
so the approach
uh that had to be taken in Mexico with
some of the approach you were taking
Afghanistan during a war some of the
overt militaristic type approaches to
security that we had to adopt you know
from uh
we didn't move him in a single armored
vehicle we had two of them that looked
exactly alike so when we would move
around we would switch one car through
the other every now and then we would
arrive to an event they would open the
door and it would be one of us and they
were like Hey where's the governor he's
in the back one so he moved to that so
we had to do stuff like that
and again this is a young me who didn't
have any specialized training I was I
was on YouTube
learning learning some of these things
uh going online learning about armored
vehicles learning about architectural
armor I think you just described a large
percentage of the Ukrainian military how
they operate which is on YouTube trying
to figure out how to use some of this
techno and and uh that's actually
incredibly effective yeah you know I'll
do quite a lot of stuff where I'm
totally not an expert totally uneducated
and so on it's kind of surprising how
quickly you can get caught up as we're
talking offline if you take a course if
you talk to an expert if you learn from
an expert you can like catch up really
quickly for me it was all of a sudden I
have this uh director calling me in and
I'm wearing Vans you know in jeans you
know t-shirt and all of a sudden I had
80 80 some people that I had to move
around and I was in charge of uh
securing planes and uh which I what do I
know about that airport hangers uh
armored vehicle maintenance and and
purchasing and figuring out how to set
up a counter assault uh group for for a
protection detail and I was like where
I'm gonna learn all this
be able to quickly figure figure some of
these things out on the Fly basically
you know as I was going I remember
having this experience uh being in the
uh our security office on my laptop
figuring out how to set up a counter
surveillance uh aside to our protection
detail basically how to have people
looking for people that might be looking
for us you know type thing
and then going to
uh San Diego to Coronado
and training with some people from uh
former seal guys and NCIS people who did
that job in war zones
and seeing them
critique some of the solutions that we
came up with on the Fly and being like
Oh we never saw that before Oh yeah this
is we're doing it down there so getting
that compliment and also getting their
you know feedback like we probably do
this or do that and it's it was a
learning process on the Fly that was
pretty I mean seat of your pants level
is it possible for the family
and for the high value person to um to
have a sense of normalcy to have a
normal life I mean I tried I was already
starting off on the on the wrong foot
basically because trust had been
violated by the people that I was
replacing so I had to gain that back
than young kids in that family that
wanted to have a you know go out and
stuff like that in the most violent city
on the planet
so I had to do my homework and figure
out places where they were safe to go to
and
make friends with certain club Owners
and figure out ways to put Security in
some of these places and having to
create this bubble of normalcy around
some of these people was pretty
difficult and uh there's no way that
that is a normal for anybody and
you know God bless them the the I know
it didn't I know it wasn't easy and I
know that it affected our lives and they
they lost on a big part of their youth
being under that that security
supervision and bubble
does probably does a lot uh for for
somebody specifically growing up like
that you know uh you lose opportunities
of
things that we take for granted you know
just going up just not telling anybody
and going to the store you know because
you want to get some snacks or something
like that that's not available to some
of these people
I have to be honest when I was in
Ukraine that was a really big benefit
you'd Escape no I couldn't hang out I
couldn't eat when I'm stressed I would
fast and not eat much so I get lost
weight this was great it's great for the
diet that's a good thing basically be
under protective custody that's a that's
a that's a good idea for a good yeah you
diet and just life it allowed me to
focus get a lot of reading done uh focus
on the important things in life
I mean uh I joke of course but there's
some
there's some complexity to this in terms
of normalcy of the family
but also just how to operate like have a
mental Clarity and a lack of fear just
basically be good at your job whatever
that job is if as a politician as a
leader uh even as a soldier somebody
that I like and I think this believes
that Ola said this to me or said
something like this to a group of us
that there's nothing wrong with being
paranoid it's about educating your
paranoia and knowing what to be afraid
of
if you're afraid of everything you know
you're basically overwhelmed but if you
start educating yourself as far as
specifically what to prioritize as far
as what to worry about
in a war zone working protecting
somebody you know you're not looking at
everybody's faces you're just looking at
their hands because that's what's going
to kill you
you know that's an example of focalizing
you know what you're paranoid and what
you're afraid of so looking at the hands
that's the specific to the particular
situation but also figuring out which
situations to avoid and which yeah it's
okay I mean that's like ultimately one
of the biggest things you could do route
analysis you know you you have to get to
the airport and you send off two cars to
analyze two routes and then on the Fly
you just change
trajectory to to create Randomness an
unpredictability and have that as a
security feature
um having to a convoy of four vehicles
separated into two convoys and show up
different in different parts to again
make it hard for people to guess where
you're going to be